la cité de la gastronomie à tour depuis
2015 le projet vieux serpent de mer n'a
cessé de changer au gré des fluctuations
politiques
aujourd'hui la nouvelle mairie
écologiste veut en faire une vitrine
pour la ville
deux autres gros chantiers sont à
l'étude notamment aux halles et au
sanitas les détails avec paul boyer et
rémy carton la cité internationale de la
gastronomie va bientôt reprendre du
service à tour cet après midi des élus
de toute la région centre val de loire
étaient présents à la villa rabelais
situé juste derrière moi pour détailler
le futur de ce lieu chargé d'histoire
trois axes autour de la gastronomie ont
été mis sur la table
le premier est la création d'une
médiathèque gourmande au rez de chaussée
de la villa rabelais dès le 9 juin
prochain chercheurs étudiants mais aussi
passionné de gastronomie pourront s'y
rendre pour se plonger dans des ouvrages
qui retrace le patrimoine culinaire de
la région pour toutes celles et ceux qui
s'intéressent à la cuisine et à la
gastronomie il y aura tous les livres
qui font l'actualité de ces sujets qui
seront présentés régulièrement ici la
deuxième nouveauté ne se situera pas à
la villa rabelais mais bien aux halles
de tours dans les étages des halles des
restaurants un espace de dégustation et
des expositions culinaire verront le
jour d'ici quelques années des ateliers
d'animations autour de la gastronomie
seront mis en place pour les enfants un
projet novateur qui nécessite des
travaux conséquents
le but c'est que ce soit un espace
multiples nuances en 1900 mètres carrés
vous avez quand même pas mal de place
donc potentiellement des espaces de
dégustation des espaces de cours de
cuisine ou en tout cas de d'ateliers de
cours de cuisine on pourra venir
chercher les produits bas du rez de
chaussée des halles et les cuisiner au
dessus il peut y avoir des espaces
d'expositions temporaires aux six autres
la gastronomie le troisième volet
portera sur l'aspect social et solidaire
de la cuisine dans le quartier du
sanitas c'est le chef cuisinier thierry
marx qui créera une école cuisine mode
d'emploi une structure d'insertion qui
formera des jeunes commis de cuisine en
semaine
l'ambition c'est qu'elle s'installe mais
plutôt à l'horizon 2023 probablement
2024 et mais comme ça dit at on pu
savoir différentes initiatives autour de
la gastronomie solidaire pour tous avec
des cuisines participative
ces développements autour de la
gastronomie s'inscrivent dans une
volonté de la région d'assumer un
tourisme culinaire axé sur l'écologie ça
pose vraiment le cadre de ce territoire
qui est le jardin de la france le jardin
de la france avec une histoire un moment
où nos concitoyens ont envie de se
réapproprier les enjeux de
l'alimentation à part entière la mise en
valeur des produits de terroir
tourangeau s'inscrit dans une volonté
politique de dynamiser la cité
internationale de la gastronomie avec un
objectif intéresser tous ceux qui
s'intéressent à l'art du bien manger et
du bien boire